[Music]
all right how many of you guys have that
doorbell thing that is a nester ring
that also has a camera I do eat well I
do but I don't have that what's the
craziest [ __ ] you guys seeing so far me
like standing out in front of nothing
happens in our neighborhood putting your
groceries down to take your keys out
open it that's pretty crazy I just have
a shotgun that's tied to the door it'll
go off it's like a trick trap it's a
little too crazy with there was a
raccoon I was kind of bothering us by
like because the trash bins are in front
of our garage and I one day it was like
2:00 a.m. I got the alert it was like
[ __ ] raccoon so I know like Oh nerf
guns and I was shooting it till it went
away I'm scared oh forget this so then
like maybe like a couple nights later we
we tied up our trash bins yeah I see the
raccoon kind of you know put off like he
get the low alert again and this
[ __ ] dude went up the stairs of
my house up to my door like my foot door
and was like there and then went back
into where he was playing has yap homies
or no I suppose I mean there's so me
yeah but that first one I was shooting
with the Nerf darts and I wasn't hitting
him I think he thought it was food at
first without I would shoot one and it
would like land and he would go dude we
used to have a bunch of them like they
would come and I'll chase them into the
trees I try to throw tennis balls of
them but they would catch that [ __ ] what
yeah yeah all right so does this guy
they were Peck had eyes on his camera
how do you make this big double she said
that's what he said - mm-hmm this one
his camera this is what he saw that's
like he's awful guys ready focus that
dinosaur just wait wait this is an alien
Christmas tree is that a gator [ __ ]
alligator oh wait where is this phone
that in the forum is this front door
that's a weird front door entrance right
then is
how low is his damn camera maybe that's
just like his garage or your why is his
camera so low yeah cuz the gear is
really low but maybe you have to go
downstairs to enter the house and so I
that's a gated with like long ass
[ __ ] legs yeah well that was a pretty
big Gator though I mean look like it was
so this is what he actually saw oh my
gosh in front of his door he has this
plaque with Turtles on it and this
alligator climbed up the bench to go
bite the Turtles what it was hungry and
this is a 5:30 in the morning wait so it
could it was it dark like they could see
the turtle from that far and I guess
they're like turtle turtle TransLink so
this guy he was just showing and then
his alert went off at 5:30 in the
morning oh sure what is it and he looks
through his ring thing and then he sees
the alligator climbing up trying to bite
the turtle and good thing he didn't
break the plaque but on the way down he
broke one of the pots so what are the
plans for alligators had a good sense of
smell and poor eyesight how did there's
no scent coming from that from that
turtle plaque is there oh yeah what the
[ __ ] is it going in a visually
stimulated well they sprayed a turtle
spray on it so it was not like a turtle
to me maybe I don't know alligators a
turtle like I don't know that was their
food gone through that shell yeah you
should see some videos online of them
like chomping on like it's pretty sad
reptile reptile crime yeah they chop em
they just see blood just starts I
thought they liked fish
well we mammals know they eat people
they just pulled on alligator or at
least I think was alligator and they
pulled off it was like an Indonesia or
something they pull a whole [ __ ] guy
on a person was he like I kept [ __ ]
breathe thank God it's like rich Brian
fixing the insiders have a sad occasion
he was that know those alligators and
like pythons that are trying to kill
each other so the pythons trying to
suffocate the alligator pythons trying
to eat the alligator an allegation to
eat the Python as you can see like the
alligator on the predator against
predator yeah dude I love watching those
Emmy I feel sad for who dies this is a
death match for sure and there's it's
weird but then like at the same time
it's like watching into MMA fights like
its nature bro you know [ __ ] a win
that's that's not as sad as them getting
like a little baby deer yeah oh I don't
want to other predators take each other
out that's pretty cool yeah
this isn't predator vs. predator but you
know those [ __ ] Komodo dragons you
know how crazy those [ __ ] are they're
so dangerous there'll be a deer that's
just sitting and offal will come up and
just bite you and eat you while you're
like sleeping they're [ __ ] big too
are they the ones with venom no it's got
the tongue the way dragons like lizards
oh I also read I think they have so much
[ __ ] bacteria in their mouth that
after they bite you you will get
infected though Wow it's like not it's
not really venom but they're just a
media in their mouth okay STD you know
anybody with bearded dragons they're
kind of cool they're like super cuddly
apparently like I was reading a Chrissy
Teigen tweet she was thinking about
getting one she's like let me know like
if you have one and show me pictures and
stuff and people were just posting all
of their bearded dragon pets and stories
and stuff the lizard's with the big
cheeks yeah that looks like they're
smiling
no they're spikey cuz okay so I shot
like an animal so one time and we we
were there was a big [ __ ] pink lizard
with giant cheeks and he was super
cuddly like you just have me arms
they're super cuddly it's probably it I
just kept reading all of their cute
stories like it was like the best
quarantine tweet read I've ever read hmm
I just like the ones where they see like
they catch them on the street on like
the pavement and they're like standing
on their legs and like they're run at
you with their all the ones that go
across water oh okay yeah
huh that's if that's what you're
thinking up that's not what I know
that's not what I thought that's what he
was thinking of that was what he was
thinking know that none duh not that I
was gonna be there I was the boss yeah
duck sounds looks like the dinosaur from
Jurassic Park about aquatic salamanders
they are cannibals they eat each other
in the tank but they're already smiling
a little sociopath Oh God did you have a
salamander I did but it was I don't know
if it was that I mean it was it was it
had a red belly and it was black black
it had to be a water yeah and I had a
frog and my mom lost my frog because she
was helping me clean my tank and then
like she was like I don't know where
your frog way and I'm like oh she
thought I was gonna be devastated and I
was just like ah but and then she was so
dramatic about it I had to [ __ ]
comfort her ass so she wanted I'm like
it's cool what kind of frog was it a
leopard what the heck smaller it spotted
it's it looks like it's it's like it's
your typical green frog with the spots
is it poisonous no no no what do you
name your pets I didn't like really name
um okay I thought the turtle I did his
name was Earl and I [ __ ] made a story
of bottom two it was a ready or slider
no that was a desert tortoise yeah and
that food died cuz I didn't feed them
dude my friend had eels and they kept
trying to escape from where from the
tank day fish fish tank right next to
the eel tank yeah and even she kept
trying to escape to get into the fish
tank
well I'm like that's so scary imagine
like you wake up and the Eels just like
right there oh yeah I had a friend Yetta
arowana
arowana this silver fish in the front of
like a Chinese restaurant it goes like
this
mmm tongue sticks out but it's native to
like the Amazon River okay
and so how they hunt in nature is
they'll see like a bug on a branch oh
it's so cool oh the job yeah
and grab it and come back down yeah so
my friend had a tank I was pretty big in
this room and sometimes you would come
home and we don't see the fish and this
was just laying outside oh my god it
happened we don't know how long he's
been gasping for air screen on it but
then he'll find like like a little yeah
area maybe there was a fly so this would
jumps out and then lands on the ground
what Clark sometimes we throw him back
in these any still survives but depends
on how long he's been out yeah I had the
same fish it's [ __ ] nuts dude it's
like finding Nemo you know like this
long dude dad it's like they're fancy
they have like a nice tail and it's like
a dragon that's probably too smaller and
closer for them to well it's the same
thing we're like if you have like a
little topper thing and there's this
little [ __ ] couple inches on the side
open don't find a way to jump through it
yeah yeah Arowana it makes sense now air
damn I got hella good turning radiuses
to go like this we go so funny he's got
a hell of good tournament you know this
is the first time in my life that I
don't have any pets like this this kind
of like phase in my life now what do you
want to travel huh yeah I do you feel
lonely in quarantine with no oh I
thought I would but I get a lot of
fulfillment looking at other people's
dogs and I'm like cool I'm going to
sleep oh I do that what porn cuddle
you're like I combine both doggy porn Oh
like a furry
no no yeah yeah yeah house doesn't feel
complete without pets for me it doesn't
feel like a home okay I need it I need
that little snuggle uncle pet but it's
also a burden sometimes because then
you're like like like let's see if we go
out for like if we go to Disneyland
right and if we want to stay long we
usually have to get like one of Gio's
nephews or nieces to come and like house
it yes my cats are better I know that's
the part that's I've never had a pet
get a cash kit well we were gonna either
get a cat or a little dog like we're
thinking about it for a while but then
we're just
like having a kid that's like I'm more
of a dog person
hmm I heard news damn I saw [ __ ] dope
ass cat outside outside you guys really
like a cow me that's the mall now move
she was separated from a small man she
didn't even want the baby back we try to
add words well hey mom we found your kid
and she's like take me on me Ari I love
it
[Music]
[Music]